あれ ブッダの推薦 今言ったのは現代人に説法で
仏教ではもっとすごい難しいことを言うんですね
不満を克服する道があるんです
だから不満っていうのは徹底したものでも生きることそのものであって
しかし それって克服する方法あるんです
不満を完全に消す方法あるんです
それは側変二つに分けます
まず 悪行為をやめる 一般人に今一般人のところ
側変だから それで不幸になることはなくなる
ね 悪行為をやめたらね
まあ悪いことないでしょう
善行為をする 期待通りに生きることができるんですよ
善行為をすると よく勉強すると
自分好きな仕事見つかるでしょうに
感情を制御する 理性に生きられる
感情を制御するだけで理性的な人間になるんです
慈しみを育てる 平和で皆と仲良く生きられます
そうすると競争で苦しまないんですよ
慈しみがあれば競争しても苦しくはないんです
それは俗編出世間編 そこへまた
メモを取るならば出しますけど
項目が一つしか書いてないんです
これ出世間の成功 それで収めます
そんなもんで はい それから出世間に入ります
すべては無常だ 実体のないものだ
瞬間瞬間変わっていくものだと観察するんです
思っただけではダメです
調べていくんです 幻覚
蜃気楼に引っかかっていて苦しんでいるのだ
それを発見するように捨てる
我々は幻覚に 蜃気楼に引っかかって苦しんでますよ
この幻覚は何やと発見するんです
この蜃気楼って何やと
すべては瞬時に変わるので捨てることならんです
とっても変わっているでしょうに
意味がないんですよ だから田中さんがBというものを欲しくても取れないんだからね
それで中田さんがCをいただきますけど
関係ないんです だから田中さんがBを欲しがったところで
まあいいやと これ得られないんだと
初めからもうと捨てることならんです
執着したくても 本来は執着は成り立たないと発見するように努めるんです
今日早く終わると思ったんですけど
かなり時間取りました
執着すると失望する 苦しむ
だから本当に苦しみというのは執着から生まれるんです
無常からじゃないんです
あの不満だからでもないんです
執着なんです 捨てて捨てて先に進む
生きることは不満を満たすことじゃなくて
捨てることやと だからブッダのブッダの世界では
もう捨てて捨てて捨てて捨てていく訓練するんです
無常の現象の中で満足を探すのは
火の中で氷を探すことと同じだと理解するんです
火の中で氷を探してはないんだからね
俗世間では火の中で氷探してます
仏教はもう諦める 捨てるのないとはっきりわかるんです
外の世界 自分の体 自分の心
どちらでも無常なので
完全無執着を体験するんです
最後に 外の世界が無常
自分の体も無常 自分の心も無常
だったら全部捨てるぞと
全部捨てるということで
完全無執着という心ですね
それを心じゃない そのそれを経験するんです
で終わるんです それでそこで初めて最高な安らぎを経験するんです
お釈迦様推薦している解脱っていうのは
涅槃っていうのはこの最高の安らぎなんです
それで終了ですよ 不満ということは
だから悟らない限りは不満はなくなりません
だから不満なくすというよりは
不満とどうすれば仲良くできるのかということは
俗世間で考えなくちゃいけないことです
それで話は一応終了になります
はい そういうわけで どうもありがとうございます
はい